okay so the first trailer for
ghostbusters has come out and I feel
like given how passionately I feel about
this project I did a video on it once
before feel free to go back and check
that out but I feel kind of obligated
that I need to talk about this thing now
my initial gut reaction to this thing
was not good but I I know that that
mostly has to do with just my love of
the original and I mean love the
original Ghostbusters is my favorite
movie of all time
ever so anything retreading that is
gonna be starting off in a bad place and
that would have been true if this had
been a proper Ghostbusters three with
the original cast I still would have had
an initial reaction to it I'm pretty
sure so I watched it a second time and
while the things that I didn't like were
still there I was able to pick out some
things like okay okay maybe there's
something here now if I were to try and
break down it's about a 50/50 split for
everything that I say that was like okay
maybe there was something else that made
me go oh god why that having been said I
did like sort of the initial mood and
tone of the thing this sort of more
lower key little slightly spooky I liked
seeing the logo sort of spray-painted on
the wall in the subway that actually
that feels really organic and is a
pretty neat way to get the logo in in a
way that doesn't feel like we just don't
feel logo and did this like cuz that I
lived in New York that's the sort of
crap somebody would have spray-painted
in the subway
then we get three out of four of the
Ghostbusters confronting what is
probably their first ghost in what is
very much a mirror of the classic
library scene from the beginning of the
first Ghostbusters now again how much it
is mirroring that old movie annoys me
because I've really come to the
conclusion like if you are going to
reboot if you're going to if it's not a
remake but a reboot you're throwing out
the old continuity doing your own thing
then do your own thing
so how much it was deliberately echoing
that old scene annoy me that said the
effects on the ghost diagnosis at least
look pretty good and I kind of liked it
when it started just vomiting the slime
all over I'm like okay
I said
josè at the slime somebody I was kind of
like oh whatever but sort of the initial
three that we see I kind of like their
vibe and they feel like fairly new
characters they feel pretty original I
can't immediately look at that initial
group of the three the the engineer the
particle physicist and whatever Melissa
McCarthy is I can't look at them and
immediately go
that's the REA that's the Egon that's
the Peter and I like that but then we
get the fourth one added in and I don't
like her I'm just gonna chalk that up to
the performance I found her immediately
grating and she rubbed me the wrong way
and then we saw some more of the ghost
effects and the more I saw of them the
less I liked them because I could spot
the CGI much better and they've gotten
the lunch of the shot we saw of slime or
all you know I hate that he's in this
cuz again it's a reboot do your own
thing the other thing I don't like about
this trailer is that it tipped his hand
on a couple of the things that do seem
like new ideas like we hear someone say
someone created a device that's
amplifying supernatural energies well
don't tell me that in the trailer
because that's a completely no idea the
idea that these aren't portents to some
big mystical you know evil god thing
like they were in the original but
instead this is kind of almost a
man-made problem that's a new take it's
a new speak and I know I sound
hypocritical zone cuz I might give me
something new but then I'm yelling at
them for the new things that they are
giving me but I mean this thing's
banking so much on nostalgia I kind of
would have preferred if I gone in
expecting a reheated plate of nostalgia
that I was gonna hate and got surprised
with new ideas but I mean that's not
gonna surprise me now and then in
addition to that is the whole possession
thing now possession is not completely
new to ghostbusters but it's been pretty
selective the keymaster the gatekeeper
ray in the second one it's not kind of a
more free-for-all o slime though you're
possessed now the thing that we seem to
be getting from this and again that
could be an interesting new take but
you've now spoiled one of the few new
things that you could have surprised me
with in the theater so thanks as far as
the humor goes the jokes landed better
for me when they didn't linger on them
like the best laugh that this thing got
for me is when they're all lined up and
they're like let's get let's go and like
they both try and say it at the same
time you're like Oh next time we'll
figure this out that
good moment it's going quick keep going
which was the kind of humor the original
Ghostbusters did dialogue toss off and
then the thing keeps moving cuz it's got
places to be or another good example for
the trailers with Melissa McCarthy just
her hand ah that's hot but then you know
you give me a brace you just gonna keep
going we're not gonna linger on that but
then we got let's linger on the hearse
and let's linger on on this woman
slapping Melissa McCarthy heck let's
have her slap her again it's like these
moments that they went out of their way
to be like here's the joke that they
didn't land they didn't work for me and
I'm gonna say probably not
coincidentally they mostly involved the
character who I liked the least like I
said there's good there's bad I'm not
gonna say it was all crap there's
potential here but like I said for
everything I'm seeing that so I'm like
maybe I'm seeing something else that
makes me go ah I like the look of their
outfits I like the look of ecto-1 I'm
kind of neutral slightly intrigued by
the fact that it looks like they're
based out of a Chinese restaurant I like
the way the theme song was it great I
like the sound of it cuz it's it's still
very much that 80's vibe but it's you
know it's just slightly more it's it's
this like it's been tweaked it's been
auto-tune which just seems actually very
fitting for this movie as a whole but
I'm really gonna try and get myself into
a better mental place to when it
eventually comes around and I have to
sit down and watch this movie because
like I said my first impression watching
the trailer was all bad I watched the
second time and I could see some good in
it now I'm hoping that doesn't mean I'll
have to sit down and watch the movie two
times I'm hoping I can just you know
witness as kind of a base level just get
myself in a good mental place to be able
to take it on its own terms as much as
impasse as possible because if I end up
not liking it I would like it to be
because the movie fails in and of itself
not because it just wasn't my favorite
movie ever because it's not going to be
it's never going to be so we'll see what
happens Ghostbusters trailer have you
seen it what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were dropped something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it please feel free to like
subscribe follow me on Twitter check out
the council of geeks podcasts on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned